um
[Music]
oh yes yes speaking of fascist
morons
let's let's take a look this is a guy at
the trump rally this week in the same
rally where he said that he he should
execute i mean fire
not execute sorry
he didn't say that yet his fire
government officials
whenever and wherever he wants for
whatever reason just for being
dissidents let's listen to this [ __ ]
he might die first uh gabe's joining us
here gabe did you hear that did you hear
this knucklehead here at the trump rally
yeah and i heard covet say all right
hold my [ __ ] beer huh yeah oh my [ __ ]
it's like you'll have to kill me first
and it's like literally like copen in
the grim reaper hand in hand they're
like okay yeah cool cool welcome gabe
welcome welcome to the show
everybody welcome gabe um you know this
this really is uh this guy here is kind
of like uh trumpism in 15 seconds right
like oh yeah like here's the thing
i actually because this guy won't get on
a plane because there's a mass mandate
right i actually that is more of a
reason for everyone to be like you know
what we're just gonna sacrifice and
everyone's gonna wear mask on a plane so
dumb bucks like this never get on a
plane again right like the funny the
funny thing is he he's like oh you know
if the stewardess ever does this to me
and i'm like okay one not called
stewardess anymore right right
but i made a i made a video called uh
maga airlines and i have that as a joke
literally at the end when it's like make
sure to inform your flight attendant i'm
sorry i mean stewardess no if you'd like
your magazine i forgot what the line is
but uh i have that exact line in there
where he says the right term and then
corrects himself to be incorrect
and says stewardess instead of uh well
that's because they're totally
predictable though right i mean again we
have such a hard time sometimes doing
satire of these people like because
they're so out in front of us like we
can't even we can't even get out in
front of these [ __ ] like even
the videos we made this weekend people
were commenting and they're like
wait is it is this right some of them
thought it was real yeah like some
people were like oh is this real audio
like you guys did the video or whatever
but like is this from real people right
right and that's where we are right now
where most people are like i don't it
sounds so dumb and it's so ridiculous
that i've come to accept there's like an
80 chance that it's real you know why i
do i do want to say we are going to play
we are going to play the commercial
that gabe is talking about today or
excuse me the video during the
commercial break
um
here in just a bit um of of the video
that gabe's talking about where it's
called letters
uh of the trucker convoy and uh jojo
from jurors wrote a tweet i i i had this
vision in my head when i seen the tweet
and uh i proposed to her that we should
do
um these these letters in a video and it
worked out perfect yeah and every
everyone really likes them because they
they are hilarious yeah yeah yeah but
the thing is is you could
you could actually see them saying these
things oh hands down yeah i mean you
look at this guy right here and he's a
walking parody like
just just the embodiment of trumpism
it's the same thing whenever i see
people who are like
uh
i don't i know a bunch of republicans
and none of them say that you know or
they're like uh i'm republican and i've
literally never said that and i'm like
whether that's true or not uh the fact
of the matter is that these people exist
and then what's hilarious is those
people say
uh
that it's not in fact
uh something that's said but then they
double down and then validate the
character
by saying the like almost they can
almost as if they continue the the
conversation
of what that character that i had
would continue to say
and i'm like you
you denied that
it's like when i made a video about uh
republicans on halloween and all the
things that they would say to
trick-or-treaters like oh socialism free
candy and all this stuff like gotta work
for it like you know put yourself up by
bootstraps and go up in the tree
and people are like oh
i've never heard someone say that and
then they double down and then say
something that sounds so dumb
as if it was the republican handing out
candy or rather not handing out candy on
halloween
uh and i'm like well thank you very much
for just you know further validating the
character that i'm i'm i based this on
so
it it is it again it is hard to satire
these idiots right here's another
example right here
the over the weekend ron desantis let me
take the banner down so we can see so
the people on the screen can see this
but over over the uh the weekend
ron desantis calls disney woke
what the [ __ ] does this even mean
anymore like they literally have watered
down the word woke so much like what are
like last week we were talking about
like if joe biden is sleepy j biden and
he's woke biden right like it's two
different things like what do you mean
by woke dis right and also all of the
people who are always like oh you got to
get awake you got to see what's going on
you got to open your eyes you know it's
like so if i'm awake i would be woke
right right right right you know it's
it's so dumb and the thing is like you
know we talk about woke sky and they
just throw woken and this and that like
as if it's a bad thing where it's like
oh god forbid i wanted to care for
another human being or like i want to
respect what their uh what their
whatever with their lifestyle their way
of living
their choices like you say my body my
choice you should in fact respect those
choices of another person and what they
do with their body or with their lives
right it's not actually affecting you or
hurting your your your body so shut the
[ __ ] up
well i i mean this goes back to what i
was saying earlier is these these [ __ ]
are
you know they they they doing this
messaging [ __ ] you know like the
pro-life thing but here they are trying
to pass laws in states
texas apparently someone's floated an
idea
that they want to make a medical
procedure that a woman would have
punishable by the death penalty
think about this pro-lifers are so
pro-life they're so [ __ ] pro-life
that they want to make sure that if a
woman makes the choice to save her own
life with an eptopic pregnancy
that they just might kill her i i can't
even you can't even [ __ ] start i
think it's most people i bet you if you
ask them what that was they would be
like oh yeah it's a pregnancy when in
fact it's just the it's it's a it
it's right well it has the word
pregnancy in it right right yeah but you
look at it and it's like okay if i were
to you know like stop someone on the
street and say hey do you know what an
ectopic pregnancy is they'd be like uh
pregnancy and you're like well what if
someone wanted to abort that ectopic
pregnancy and you're like yeah that's
bad right that's what they would say but
really it's like oh [ __ ] this person
could die because it's actually a
practice that's happening
not where it should be
so it's just
i i mean well you're not you're not
gonna get you're not
it sucks to suck it really does sucks to
suck and and their ideas suck they know
they suck so what they're trying to do
is gather up as much [ __ ] crazy ass
support on the internet that they can
here
and they're trying to be as loud as they
possibly can uh here's another example
of it right here speaking of texas and
and non-pro-life pro lifers ted cruz
here's a press conference and listen to
what one of the truckers in the thing
yells out
you look at the origins
uh of the pandemic
the virus
ted cruz sucks i mean there's no more
truth than you can even tell wait can
you open that back up
i want to point something out to the
audience
uh see this guy in the red
black checkered shirt here so this guy
over here yeah yeah his name is brian
brace or brian
tell us about brian
brian
uh
a few days ago
called in
uh one of the people that called into
9-1-1
okay so so so wait a second you're
talking about at the trucker convoy yeah
yeah uh at the trunk of convoy there was
some there was an an incident or
multiple incidents right where people
were driving by the truckers and they
were
they were as he said
throwing the bird there were birds
flying everywhere oh boys were flying
were they tweeting were they tweeting
because you know it wasn't okay i've
actually got a video uh coming out today
do they have did they release the dubs
i'm not sure what it wasn't doves they
weren't throwing it he was like you know
throwing a big bird at him you know
nothing like that it was
as in throwing a bird like flipping you
off so he calls into nine one oh the
middle finger right middle finger
mj says here fat wolverine does suck oh
yeah with a super chat thank you mj
thank you
uh but brian over here uh is
you know a guy who wants to he's a
champion of freedom
free speech and
all things liberty right and then no
mandates
no mandates woman dates you know right
and uh
and
i feel like we're getting a sneak
preview of the video already
i didn't i did not put that in there did
not put that in maybe maybe maybe they
just slide in no mandates only woman
woman dates are the only thing women
women can't throw the finger men you
know what that might be i might have to
do a second video now
maybe it's a part two yeah i mean they
it's the same same same as the the
letters it's just constant just
uh material but anyway brian here calls
into 991 did did an interview and
complained about how these people up
there were so mean and no one from from
once they started the convoy was ever
that mean no one was flipping them off
and so he calls in and he tells everyone
because he's also an organizer he's one
of the guys who started this whole thing
in the u.s and he complained and said
you should flood 9-1-1 and we should get
them to tell uh all of these people on
the road wait wait wait so he called 9-1
or he encouraged everyone to call 99 uh
i believe he called on both but also
encouraged others to flood 9-1-1
meanwhile the
state is like please don't do that do
not do that flipping someone off is not
an emergency not an emergency uh i'm
sorry that your feelings were hurt
because somebody in their own car
decided to [ __ ] throw you the bird
and you were all upset in your big old
boy truck you know and honk your horn
and fighting for freedom and all of a
sudden as soon as someone just throws
something so just
slight like this as you drive by they go
that's mean gabe don't do that that is
mean i'm the victim
that is exactly what's happening so
that's brian ryan is a big snowflake uh
and he is melting and this isn't big as
in uh snow flaky big or he's just like
six foot two six with three i don't know
how tall he is because i don't know how
fat wolverine is so it's hard to get a
perspective but what i will say is uh
he's just a a bigly baby you know right
well is he is this the same guy because
i'm not sure these these two guys on the
flanking
um um the snow lizard here that's what i
call takers the snow lizard i like fat
wolverine yeah yeah but snow lizard you
know that that's my nickname for him so
the flanking the snow lizard here isn't
one of these guys is it brian that had
the little that had the stage set up the
weekend before last week was that who it
was yeah yeah so he was like the only
one that him in like 20 media oh oh that
one uh
good question i would have let me look
it up really quick
i mean i mean it looks i i mean i can't
tell because you know um from the video
that i think you posted um or that you
shared i believe of the rally or the or
the little where he had the stage right
i think his family was there maybe a few
of his yeah the ratio was like 30 to one
it was like 30 reporters in one of him
right right uh
but yeah he
i'm not sure if that's the guy i'm not
sure
yeah all i know is that this guy is the
one that's behind organizing the the us
uh people's convoy
and
uh
he's the biggest baby because he was
like well i didn't get what i wanted or
like call
911 for people who have not uh traveled
in a [ __ ] semi truck before that [ __ ]
is loud okay right you got you you are
above people so you would have to be
actively looking down
at the card next to you to see someone
flip you off and even if someone flipped
you off in front of you it'd be like
whatever you know some no big deal that
is their freedom of speech the thing you
are in fact
fighting for right right well that's
what they say right exactly but remember
freedom of speech
until i feel uncomfortable and then you
got to shut the [ __ ] up speaking of semi
trucks and writing and semi trucks let
me see if i can
um grab there was a guy
um yeah here it is there was a guy who
who tried to climb out of a semi truck i
don't know if you've seen this oh yeah
um let's see let's see i think yeah i
got it here okay this this is this is a
semi truck that maybe a certain um
uh snow lizard or someone who would run
away from texas when it got you know a
little cold the cancun
this is how he got out of us i wonder
how he got in i wonder there's video of
that but this is how i think i think
i've seen a video of him getting in did
it take like three or four people to get
him up in there because it really
i don't know they weren't sure if he was
gonna get out because when he gets out
you'll see what they do watch this okay
oh
don't grab that one where's my foot oh
the thing is that this it's only like
three and a half four feet and there's
steps there so you could just
jump down yeah you did it yeah
just keep just keep playing and listen
to what he says next
are you ready
good to be back he says good there's
brian by the way there's oh yeah
let's let's let's uh
there's brian was he driving no he
wasn't driving the truck i don't know i
mean he's a trucker he might have been
driving i'm not he is he is a trucker
yeah that is converter but ted cruz
comes back and i even said i made a
tweet about this i like ted cruz [ __ ]
struggles to get off this truck he sits
down you know he's zipping up his jacket
and says
good to be back like
from what the guy had just like it's as
if the guy just come back from a tour of
duty and in a war and he was like good
to be back i'd only been gone for 24
hours if that
well he was gone for 12 minutes again
the truck drove down the street got out
of the truck i mean there's canoe trips
longer than what ted cruz was in this
truck well here here here's here's the
here's a picture of this [ __ ] idiot
inside the truck here
[Music]
number one if ted cruz was so cool if
ted cruz was really so cool which he's
not he's not even close to being cool
not even close if he was so cool he
would just he would have drove the semi
truck like that's right if he was really
cool which also here's the thing i mean
semi trucks uh you know they're not
they're not easy to drive a lot of
shifting gears you know it takes it
right you know it takes it it's a skill
for sure uh
uh but i would also say that some of
those people driving those trucks
probably aren't
the brightest and i say that because of
what we're seeing right now we're
fighting over the dumbest things that
are no longer i mean what are what are
they there for really honestly well they
said that they're fighting freedom right
they're they're they're a champion
they're fighting freedom or for freedom
there are a champion for free speech in
all things liberty right other than the
middle finger that right exactly yeah
yeah uh there are perceptions they're
like oh if if if a woman throws me the
middle finger oh no uh my world has just
fallen apart right um
but because remember it it originally
started with hey we want to fight up
against these mandates and then they're
like
okay
uh but which mandates because because
there is there are no mandates like
there's no right right well there's it
was the vaccine mandates because the
truckers are like oh you know to get
back into canada or to go into the u.s
and you know we need a vaccine uh and
the truckers here but the truckers here
in this country don't have mandates it
was just a mandate to in to enter into
action yeah yeah there's no mandates in
here so it's the whole thing of like
there are it's like oh vaccine mandates
and mass command dates it's again it's
like you're in the truck for hours on
end you have literally literally like
little interaction with anyone
until you get to like wherever the
loading dock is or wherever you drop off
the
the uh the delivery so there's not a lot
of interaction and there's not a lot of
issue with like you know
spreading unless you're like
sleeping in the in the in the bed of the
truck with with right a bunch of people
but
it's the they they fight the mandates
and so then everyone's like well the
mandates are going away like what are
you doing you know and they're like well
we gotta we and i did it in a video
which
all of their arguments which again
everyone comes after not everyone but a
bunch of republicans came after me like
oh this is not this is a straw this is a
[ __ ] uh
straw man fallacy argument you know and
i'm like no it's not and if you do
believe it is then please present the
arguments that are there and everyone is
shut the [ __ ] up so basically gabe we
know that you get paid by soros to make
these arguments i mean
listen listen every video is a million
bucks
i mean that's that that's how this show
continues is right it's george soro i
mean we haven't gotten our check yet but
i mean it's in the mail but it's kind of
held up by like the convoy you know
because they're like part of the
delivery so you know right i'm sure
it'll be here next week but it's that
it's it's them saying oh we want to
fight mandates well the mandates are
going away so what are you guys really
fighting well we want to fight the fact
that there's high gas prices like okay
well then maybe you should talk to opec
i don't know or not be driving wasting
gas right exactly why are you burning
gas and diesel around the beltway you're
only okay one you're just uh furthering
uh to climate change you're you're
you're disrupting the lives of dc
residents who actually rely on the
beltway so you're actually uh
uh you're a hindrance you're
um
you're an annoyance
to uh many people within that that uh
that that area and then the other part
is then they're like well you know what
you know what people will listen to us
if we shut everything down and it's like
okay fine so you want to shut everything
down by not delivering you want to say
hey you know what those shelves that we
complained about that weren't actually
stocked but it really wasn't the problem
we're actually going to make sure that
they actually want to have that problem
yeah
this is the this is this is the the plan
is to create chaos and then blame it
on because everything's joe biden's
fault right exactly i mean it's it's all
joe biden as well i mean thanks brandon
um here is uh this is this is quite
humorous so the video that we were just
watching
and i'm not gonna play it again but but
uh nope and maybe
if my zoom works here ted cruz actually
thought it was a good idea to post that
video he said thank you to every trucker
who is standing up for freedom for every
man woman and child in america what the
what what freedom i don't know
i don't know i freed them to what to to
to have traffic on a highway i mean
literally these people were not stopped
there was nothing there was nothing done
to stop these people that no one no no
law enforcement agency prevented them
from driving around the beltway um the
only people that tried to stop anything
from happening is brian there called
9-1-1 to try to get try to get those
those those whim dates those women dates
done so they didn't give us the middle
finger we don't want them to give us the
middle finger which i think we might
have a video about but
um that you released yesterday if anyone
wants to go go to gabe's timeline you
can see the uh
the and we'll maybe we'll play him in
the second hour here but that the the
trucker convoys from letter that joe
helped us with ted your [ __ ] tweet
sucks
it [ __ ] sucks don't post the video
that makes you look like an idiot on
your own timeline not a good idea um so
let's see i think there was one other
video though that i wanted to show of
ted cruz here about the trucker convo
maybe not oh yes because it was it's
what he says when he gets out of the
truck right because he says some dumb
[ __ ] right not just him exiting but what
does he say that's what he gets that was
the thing i was saying when he gets when
he gets out he goes glad to be back or
good to be back
right but he says he says something else
he answers some questions i think he
says something else oh let's see if we
can ted cruz trucker ooh that
that feels gross to even type in
uh
[Music]
here it has chinese symbols that's
inappropriate
uh is this that's not when he gets out
there's get here's him get in oh here we
go here we go here we go everybody we
only caught that we only caught like the
second half of it so we don't know if he
struggled he went the same way he went
back up the same way as he went down
all right so
maybe maybe maybe well maybe
i don't know
where you've made it up there woohoo
you got in the truck yeah success the
fact also that a sitting u.s president
said yeah i'm gonna skip work today and
i'm gonna go for a joyride because i'm
gonna do something that is all just not
president senator don't give him that
much credit
you said president no i said i said
president i think you said president i
said i thought i said sitting senator i
think i think you said sitting president
sorry
and
so there's the press conference again
where he says he's like maybe i don't
have the video all right well let's
let's do this let's go to the commercial
uh pay attention to the commercial break
here and you'll see the video and then
when we come back we'll we'll play the
the round to the part two of the letters
from truckers convoy stay with us right
after the break we'll be right
back what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
years bob
dear bob i'm fixing to send you some
more of them doritos you like the red
bag not the lib loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
oh bob and tammy bob and tammy tammy and
bob
[Music]
letters from the trucker con
[Music]
i hope bob does uh decide to wipe his
ass at least once a day i mean
theoretically i guess i guess if you poo
one today you're gonna wipe your ass
once a day but that's not you know in
theory i guess maybe you know
i also i'm also like uh
i kind of i joked about this this
weekend i was like oh bob and tammy not
to be confused with the hulu show pam
and tommy right right you know very
different but probably very interesting
lives in some way you know it it could
probably be a reality show i don't know
hands down a lot of people were saying
that we should do a series yeah and
speaking of doing a series
here is part two
of letters from the truckers convoy here
let's um
let's play this here
letters from the trucker convoy
part two
dears tammy
today was a dark day
there i was
minding my own business cruising around
the beltway
went up come a mess of young girls
and they done gave me the middle finger
it wasn't like the
finger it was real mean like
now i'm scared
send nudes
dear bob
don't let them comment let girls it
flips you off get y'all upset
remember why you're there you're there
cuz
well
i don't really know why you're there but
don't you lose sight of it
whatever
it is
well here's a pic of my tits
sorry about the rash
stay strong
here's
tammy
[Applause]
oh my god i i can't help
just to give the audience uh the lowdown
on these videos what happened was is joe
uh these are documentaries pbs [ __ ]
ken burns [ __ ] right
well so joe jojo from jurors wrote a
tweet and it was the very first one the
letter to tammy right and and like as
soon as i read it i heard that in my
brain and i'm like oh god we got to do
like a a ken burns letter from trucker
convoy and then she wrote the follow-up
from tammy to bob and i'm like oh now we
gotta definitely do it so we recorded me
and joe recorded our voices with the
letters we sent that the game and gabe
made the video so it was a call because
it was like it was something it was i
had i was like i had woken up and i was
like doing some stuff and i got a
message and you were like hey can we do
this and i was like yeah we could do
anything whatever yeah right why not why
not
and so so not only did we uh so
so joe kept writing these things so
there may or may not be
part three part four i mean i don't know
how long some people were like
i mean i'm just saying it seems like
there's a saga like it's gonna there's
gonna be a lot right and i feel like
this is one of those things where
people might be like oh god i hate these
people but i'm growing to
i'm growing i'm going to like them right
because they seem they're like well
these are like real people with real
problems you know
right but at the same time i mean the
rash you know yeah yeah
it hasn't had a rest who hasn't been
right and there hasn't been on there
with their cousin you know right i mean
brody who everyone has a brody right
everyone's got a brody everyone's got a
brew adam adrian it's whatever you know
it's
everyone's got one and at the end of the
day uh there may be
five there might be 35 i don't know you
know it's kind of crazy you can tell who
can tell who can tell so mate so maybe
we'll do uh
maybe even maybe in this afternoon there
might be a part three tomorrow i i don't
know keep keep an eye out for
for uh bob and tammy the uh the saga of
bob and tammy i hear you might have to
go gabe
so good luck with that work today
and
i'll send over anything to be made yeah
yeah videos later on yeah look out
everyone else
say bye to gabe everyone have a good one
game bye-bye we'll talk to you soon all
right let's get back to the shitless
roundup uh oh where we round up all the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends